[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a la entrevista de
Franz 24 en español en esta emisión nos
acompaña Sergio Jaramillo él es filósofo
y filólogo colombiano ex alto
comisionado para la paz de Colombia con
él vamos a hablar sobre la guerra en
Ucrania América Latina y una muy
interesante y necesaria iniciativa que
promueve y une a estas regiones Sergio
Jaramillo Muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en la entrevista de Franz 24
Muchas gracias por la invitación Bueno
Sergio a casi un año del inicio de la
invasión rusa a Ucrania usted impulsa la
campaña aguanta Ucrania cuéntenos En qué
consiste Cuál es su origen y sus
objetivos
su origen es una preocupación de una
serie de amigos de América Latina en un
comienzo Francisco samper en Colombia
Martín china Argentina y otros expertos
en comunicación nos pusimos de acuerdo
en que América Latina tenía que tener
una voz en esta discusión no podía ser
un convidado de piedra a la mayor crisis
internacional desde Segunda Guerra y así
comenzamos y a la vez comenzamos a
hablar con diferentes gente del mundo de
las artes de escritores que se han
venido sumando y sumando sus voces en en
rechazo de esta invasión
considera quizás que América Latina o
algunos sectores No no es un bloque
uniforme por supuesto No han sido del
todo solidarios con el pueblo ucraniano
yo creo que eso no es cierto cuando uno
le pregunta a la gente uno siente que
cada vez está más claro qué fue lo que
ocurrió y cada vez hay un mayor rechazo
de esa agresión contra el pueblo de
Ucrania porque es algo que para nuestro
latinoamericanos es es muy natural Yo
siempre digo que no hay un un principio
más sagrado en América Latina que el
principio de soberanía que el principio
de no intervención tenemos sistemas
políticos absolutamente distintos en
países como Cuba o México Colombia
o Argentina pero en todas nuestras
constituciones y sobre todo en el
sentimiento de la gente La idea es que
uno invade al vecino que se toma su
territorio es algo absolutamente
repugnante que nadie acepta solo hace
falta preguntarle a la gente uno se da
cuenta que es así
Sergio Bueno usted bien decía recién no
hablaba de soberanía de
autodeterminación de los pueblos no de
la no injerencia extranjera en asuntos
internos de cada país Son elementos muy
fuertes Muy presentes en diversos sitios
de América Latina que cree entonces que
ocurre en este sentido con lo que son
las lecturas que se hacen en la región
sobre la guerra en Ucrania
pues miren en el origen de esta campaña
también está un esfuerzo para que Putin
no se salga con la suya tratando de
reversar la responsabilidad de lo que
está ocurriendo o sea Putin invadió a
Ucrania y le está creyendo creer a buena
parte del mundo que lo que ocurre Es que
él es el víctima de una agresión y que
Ucrania es simplemente un peón en una
guerra que promueve occidente y nosotros
decimos eso no es así los ucranianos
están sufriendo Y esta es una guerra
contra los ucranianos tenemos que estar
con Ucrania tenemos que devolverles su
capacidad de tener voz de tener como se
dice hoy en día agencia y a reconocerlos
como lo que son un pueblo que resiste a
una Bárbara agresión en El Siglo 21
ahora Sergio gestos Cómo esta campaña
son claves verdad y sirven muchísimo
quiero decir No solo enviar armas a
Ucrania o sancionar a Rusia son maneras
de apoyar a los ucranianos verdad
absolutamente porque más allá digamos de
Estos principios te pueden sonar
abstractos pero no lo son como la
importancia de la soberanía en América
Latina de ese principio que no está
mantenido en paz durante 150 años
básicamente está el elemento fundamental
que es el elemento humano
y es la idea no podemos dejar a los
ucranianos solos en esto tanto que hemos
sufrido en América Latina tanto que nos
hemos sentido olvidados por el mundo a
los a los ucranianos no los podemos
olvidar Y como dicen un video muy bello
en nuestra cuenta de Instagram que
además invito a todos los televidentes a
que a que lo busquen y busquenlas los
demás en nuestro hashtag hasta que
aguanta Ucrania en Instagram yoconda y
Nicaragua comienza diciendo el dolor de
Ucrania nos pertenece a todos es una
cosa tan grande inconcebible no la
podemos ignorar y lo primero que una
persona un latinoamericano es tener
empatía con ese dolor y mandarles un
mensaje de apoyo que es lo que estamos
haciendo absolutamente necesario Sergio
hablamos de los ciudadanos no al
comienzo de esta entrevista aguanta
Ucrania es una campaña que no toma
ninguna posición política frente a los
gobiernos ha dicho usted quisiera entrar
un poco En este terreno un poco más
político de la región latinoamericana un
poco lo adelantaba usted al comienzo
también de esta entrevista si bien Por
supuesto como decíamos no podemos hablar
de una América Latina Como si fuese un
bloque uniforme cuestionado no más bien
se está está fragmentado cómo evalúa los
posicionamientos de los gobiernos
latinoamericanos con respecto a la
guerra en Ucrania
América Latina está bastante fragmentada
hace ya bastante tiempo si lo admiramos
del del punto de vista de sus gobiernos
respectivos de sus relaciones entre sí
pero lo que hemos querido nosotros hacer
es decir sabe que esta vez no nos vamos
a ocupar de los gobiernos no vamos a
discutir qué opina este gobierno otro
nos vamos a ocupar la gente y hacer una
campaña desde desde la gente desde la
población de América Latina para la
población para el pueblo de Ucrania y en
eso nos hemos concentrado y a la vez
frente a este asunto de los gobiernos lo
único que decimos es lo obvio que ya
dije dígame Un gobierno en América
Latina venga de la derecha venga de la
izquierda tenga la ideología que tenga
la Constitución que tenga que esté de
acuerdo con la idea de la intervención y
de la invasión
ahora quisiera avanzar Sergio quisiera
Bueno usted hace hincapié no en que no
quiera adentrar no tanto en las
cuestiones políticas pero no quiero
dejar de hacerle esta pregunta porque
siento que quizás es un sector que
frente a conflictos de este tipo se
encuentra a veces como en ciertas
encrucijadas no me refiero a lo que son
las izquierdas latinoamericanas no Cómo
cree que se posicionan ante este
conflicto bélico
pues evidentemente parte de la
estrategia de Putin es apelar a piernas
peleanzas y simpatías históricas de la
unión soviética
eso no lo hemos visto en América Latina
sino de manera muy fuerte en África y en
partes del Asia pero yo creo que
mientras más se sale a flote la realidad
la gente más claro que es lo que está
eso ya no ya cuenta porque es una
absoluta barbaridad quién se hubiera
no sé Siglo 21
está en personas en sus apartamentos
cenando por la noche en la ciudad del
libro por ejemplo
atacando de manera intencional viviendas
matando civiles es una cosa realmente
inconcebible que puede tener mucho más
absoluto
Sergio hablaba usted recién de La era de
la unión soviética verdad cree que
quedan quizás como decirlo de alguna
manera resabios o discursos marcados
quizás por una narrativa más vinculada a
lo que fue la guerra fría todavía en
estos momentos para las lecturas de
estos conflictos claro eso es lo que
quiere revivir justamente
pero
vuelvo a decirlo la evidencia del de la
barbaridad que está cometiendo en
Ucrania está está aplastando esos
esfuerzos para la gente es cada vez más
claro qué es lo que está ocurriendo
Quién es el culpable y por qué tenemos
que estar con los ucranianos
estuvo usted Sergio en Ucrania verdad
que se trajo de aquel viaje
sí estuvo en el mes de agosto y mi
impresión como la de casi todas las
personas que que visitan es una de
francamente de admiración de admiración
frente a la serenidad con la que ese
pueblo está enfrentando invasión
nosotros no nos podemos imaginar estamos
en nuestra estoy más cerca a la guerra
porque en este momento en Bruselas
y pero no nos podemos imaginar el nivel
de destrucción de muerte que está
causando Putin en Ucrania y sin embargo
hay una decisión una decisión de
resistir y de no solamente resistir en
el campo de batalla sino resistir en la
vida diaria que a mí me impresionó
muchísimo
ver como la gente seguía con su vida
seguía yendo las oficinas yendo a los
cafés no dejándose robar la vida
te digo yo es también una forma de
resistir
y campañas como esta Sergio apuntan
quizás a ver si usted coincide conmigo
no a otra de las caras de la guerra que
en estos momentos son claves no me
refiero a la batalla por la información
no por las narrativas por los relatos de
lo que está ocurriendo este tipo de
campañas como la suya tienen mucha
influencia en esa otra cara de la guerra
verdad
Pues precisamente por esa razón también
iniciamos esta campaña Porque si usted
lo mira bien esta esta agresión contra
Ucrania esta invasión que ninguna lógica
Más allá de lo que se tejió en el
cerebro de Vladimir durante la pandemia
nadie podía prever que
y nadie encuentra una explicación
regional
Entonces estamos es un esfuerzo de
implantar una historia implantar una
narrativa decir no yo estoy haciendo
esto porque yo soy el agredido que si no
Señor usted no se le ha creído usted es
el agresor usted invadió a su destino y
hay que mantenerse en este nivel yo
llamo siempre sentido común siempre
hacemos un llamado a favor
y llamemos las cosas por su nombre
invasión es una invasión
reconozcamos esto rechacemos la
educación
la solidaridad posible con el pueblo de
Ucrania y la carga simbólica es muy
grande en esta campaña pero como bien
decíamos no queda en lo simbólico y de
hecho de los simbólicos muchas veces
salen cosas importantes verdad
pues nuevamente
cuando uno está tan difícil y en
Colombia digamos que tenemos la no sé si
llamarlo la ventaja pero como padecimos
también nuestro propio conflicto y
sabemos que es el desplazamiento de
millones de personas sabemos que es un
sufrimiento nos queda un poco más fácil
de entender eso qué es eso qué es y
hacer un llamado a todos junto con el
resto de países de América Latina a que
no deje a los ucranianos ojalá que así
sea Sergio Jaramillo Muchísimas gracias
No solo por su iniciativa también por
supuesto por su presencia en la
entrevista de Frank 24 en español
Muchas gracias por esta invitación y
nuevamente Los invito a todos a que
suban vídeos en apoyo Ucrania con el
hashtag aguante Ucrania y a que visiten
nuestras cuentas de Instagram
invitemos a toda nuestra audiencia a ser
parte de esta campaña Sergio y antes de
despedirnos los invitamos también a ver
esta entrevista y muchas más en Spotify
porque la entrevista de France 24 en
español Ya está presente en Spotify Así
pueden acceder como les decía a esta y
muchos otros contenidos los invitamos a
seguir informándose en el resto de
nuestra programación y también por
supuesto en Franz 24.com
[Música]